inspect profile inspect player what does
a level 24 look like let's Rob that
little son singer warlocks warlock
subclass who has got the solar grenade
glide radiance fill yourself with solar
light dramatically increasing the
effectiveness of your abilities melee
attack that ignites enemies in these
things of course upgrade upgrades glide
for better control upgrades radiance
that will reduce cool down for all
nearby allies interesting fireball
grenade unleashes bolts of solar light
and nearby enemies that sounds dope
arcane wisdom these are just the general
like attribute I'm gonna keep dancing
with them i think it's distracting him
keep reading yep i'll check out these
weapons real quick the renegade 813
welcome back ting 213 has like a nice
little site on it and the last round and
the magazine deals bonus damage wow
that's your right details like that
acquired from the gunsmith or dismantled
weapons and sort of working on upgrading
attack power and another site what other
weapons we got that's the hand cannon
then we've done this sniper rifle 213
does avoid damage I believe is the
purple but a very long distance scope
bonus accuracy when crouched and so this
is so this is another upgrade thing
right so the upgrades we did to our gear
we just had to pay glimmer for but this
upgrade costs weapon parts as well which
you can acquire from the gunsmith or
dismantled weapons of course old weapons
in your inventory you can dismantle if
you guys want to go back we have a dance
party going on yeah there's a dance
party she wasn't looking but like this
person seems to damn you guys have quite
the dance party this person seems to
have chosen one specific scope there are
two other scopes they could afford like
a short-range a mid-range in a long
range so a little bit more customization
for your sniper rifle depending on what
range you prefer and then we can't look
at anything everything in their
inventory but we can only look at their
equip stuff so this is the machine gun
this is why the machine gun is really
nice I
is it in the beta and I really enjoyed
it so these these upgrades actually that
are sort of stacked up you know we
choose one of them on so instead of you
know more predictable recoil they've
gone or I guess I don't know it just
manages recoil all of these to some
degree but this one doesn't this one
have to takes a range penalty bonus
accuracy when Crouch increases attack
power staggers opponents better kills
with this weapon increase reload speed
increases attack power and then there's
this whole extra upgrade I guess you can
just like really poor a lot into each
individual gun here I don't think I've
seen customization this extensive before
and the sort of beta stuff I so glimmer
spin mental and ascendant energy
required to boost the attack power even
further and then take a quick look at a
helmet sweet home and that's a pretty
sweet-looking helmet simple that's some
boba fett looking stuff it is and then
you know increase defense grenade damage
these reduces melee cool down chick
check out this I believe this dance
party is still going on people are
loving it Reese's scoutwalker I for load
speed who's whistling is that Kevin
might be Kevin or somebody nearby I
don't want to have to mute you look at
this chest armor and your stuff is hella
cool Morris 144 defense uh I want to
compare it to mines I have 34 depends
Wow yep boots 175 defense pieces scout
rifle ammo and also this my boots are 16
defense y increases your level they're
made out of paper paper boots so these
are sort of modifiers to weapon damage
done or actually sorry these numbers are
actually boost to your attributes light
and elect discipline and strength will
actually dislike discipline is strength
are attributes as I recall light just uh
can you maximize your lets you it lets
you punch above your weight basically
lets you attack enemies higher than you
and then uh Chris sweet where max level
is there a max level um well it's not I
think it might not 20 31 I can tell you
that got the ghost shell got the got a
different kind of I don't know these
things look the same what is your ship
look I'm you know come off [ __ ] don't be
a cool [ __ ] whoa we need that's pretty
cool looking that's brainy chip alright
let's do a bounty okay gals to it all
right thank you thanks shrew thank you
so much